JJ BEHRENS: The YouTube API
team's hanging out on
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm JJ Behrens.
This is Jarek Wilkiewicz, who
is so connected to email, he
is currently replying to emails
that I sent while I was
driving over.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: My mobile
is in my pocket.
JJ BEHRENS: You don't want to
know how he controls the
mobile in his pocket.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: With
my thoughts.
JJ BEHRENS: It's
pretty amazing.
In the red there is
Jeffrey Posnick.
Jeffrey Posnick, after having
mastered client-side
programming and server-side
programming, is currently
designing new sides to
programming, when it comes to
structured web development.
And then the two people there.
There's Dror Shimshowitz
and A.J. Crane.
And they're going to start us
off with the first thing we're
going to be talking about.
And since we have two visitors,
let me go ahead and
ask you guys to introduce
yourselves.
ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yeah, sure.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, go ahead.
ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Should I start?
OK.
Hi.
My name's Alex.
I'm the founder of a company
called seevl.
We built a YouTube extension
for Chrome that has music
[INAUDIBLE].
So I'd like to hear what
you're working
in the files extension.
I think this is an extension
of the Google [INAUDIBLE]
in Paris that [INAUDIBLE]
there, so I'm working on that
right now for the [INAUDIBLE].
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So you saw the presentation
in Paris.
You and I were there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: [INAUDIBLE]
I think I know what we're
talking about.
JJ BEHRENS: Right on.
And another visitor we have.
BRETT GILES: Hello there.
And my name's Brett Giles.
I'm kind of new to all
this Hangout stuff.
This is my first one.
So I thought I'd just pop in
and have a look around.
JJ BEHRENS: Say your
name again.
BRETT GILES: Brett Giles.
JJ BEHRENS: Brett Giles,
nice to meet you.
Thank you for coming.
Turn up a couple of them.
My hearing is terrible.
MALE SPEAKER: You want
to turn it up?
JJ BEHRENS: And then turn it.
There we go.
So the first thing we wanted to
talk about is Dror and A.J.
Wanted to talk about their
session that they wanted to do
a Google I/O. You guys want to
tell us about what you're
working on?
DROR SCHIMSHOWITZ: Yeah,
so Google I/O is
at the end of June.
Hopefully, a lot of
folks can make it.
What we wanted to do was
introduce and catch people up
on all the big changes that
have been happening to the
YouTube site.
We've been busy redesigning the
site all around channels
and really trying to promote
YouTube as the platform for
the next great set
of channels.
Now a lot of developers and
startups may not naturally
think that they should have
their own TV channel, their
own YouTube channel.
But there are a lot of great
opportunities to leverage this
platform to help developers and
startups with software,
hardware, or other kind of
products that they're
developing.
So what we wanted to do was
showcase how some startups and
developers are already
successfully using YouTube.
For example, there are a bunch
of startups who are doing
crowd funding, looking to secure
funding on Kickstarter
and other platforms. And
projects that have added
YouTube videos have had an
additional way to spread the
word about their crowd
funding efforts.
Also, a lot of startups can
promote their products and
start to advertise on YouTube.
And of course, we have paid
advertising products, but
there are also a lot of free
ways of getting the word out
on YouTube by uploading videos
and creating a channel that's
all about your company and
what you're trying to do.
There are a couple other ways
that we're thinking startups
and developers can
use YouTube.
So we're seeing some companies
use the platform as a way to
educate users how to
use your product.
So doing screenshots and product
demos with Hangouts on
air, like what we're
doing right now.
They can potentially provide
office hours for users who
have questions about how
to use the product.
Or even bring together users
who can educate each other
about how to best use
their offering.
And then the final one is we see
YouTube as potentially the
world's largest focus group.
So a lot of people may be
talking about your product,
showing the world
how to use it.
For example, every time there's
a new gadget out,
there are videos on YouTube
of people unwrapping it,
explaining how they're using the
product, and just showing
what they're doing with it.
And this is a great opportunity
for developers to
see what people are doing
with their products.
But also to pull that content
into their own channel and
have all this user generated
content created out there,
free of charge.
Pull that into your presence on
YouTube and just show the
world how people are using your
product without you even
have asked them to do it.
So that's kind of a high
level overview.
But if there are other topics
or things that would be of
interest, then we would love to
hear from developers about
how we can further customize
our talk.
We're just getting started on
it, so it's not too late to
ask us to include things.
JJ BEHRENS: Great, Dror.
Do you want to tell us a little
bit more about you
expected audience?
What type of person do you
expect to show up, and are
there any prerequisites?
DROR SCHIMSHOWITZ: So who we
expect to show up are startups
and developers who are thinking
beyond just coding
their product.
But they're thinking about how
to introduce their product to
the world, how to get
users, how to get
feedback from users.
And more of what we call the
cross functional aspects of
building a business.
What we're not going to dive
deep on in this talk is how to
integrate with the
YouTube API.
So it's not going to
be about that.
There are other sessions that
Jar, I think, is leading that
will talk more about that.
So it's folks at startups or
developers who have their own
startups, who want to learn
how to leverage YouTube to
connect with the world
through video.
In terms of prerequisites,
none really.
Although to the extent that
folks are familiar with the
YouTube site and have played
around with it, it'll make the
talk even more informative.
But it's not a requirement.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Wait a sec, I think I'm
getting a phone call.
Apparently, Jarek just finished
with all of this
email and is currently writing
his Google I/O talks.
Crap.
Jeffrey, I think you're
kind of behind.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I
know I'm behind.
JJ BEHRENS: The next Google
I/O talk we wanted to talk
about was getting direct
feedback from
your YouTube community.
And I might have
lost you, Dror.
Did you already cover that?
I didn't know if you covered
both of those or not?
JEFFREY POSNICK: No, I
think I was going to
talk about that, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, sorry.
Thanks, Jeffrey.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
absolutely.
No problem.
So yeah, this is one of the
talks I should be putting
together right now, but I'm
happy to describe it instead.
So I also do not want to veer
into any sort of unannounced,
unreleased technologies, though
it might be showing up.
JJ BEHRENS: Wait a second.
I thought the whole point of
doing Hangouts on air was to
subtly leak things.
I mean--
JEFFREY POSNICK: I know.
JJ BEHRENS: That's why
they're waiting here.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That was
kind of a metaleak.
Let me just make it known that
this is one of the sessions
that you're going to want to
check out either live or after
the fact, where I'll
be posting videos
for all these sessions.
So people who can't attend
Google I/O will be able to
watch it pretty soon after the
session actually happens.
And yeah, we're going to be
announcing something pretty
exciting that's related to
soliciting feedback from
developers.
And this is obviously
video feedback.
So that's one piece.
That's one hint as to what
might be going on.
And we make it easier
for people to--
JJ BEHRENS: So much video
feedback from your community.
I can't think of any
way to do that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: So this ties
a little bit into YouTube
Direct, which is
not unreleased.
This is our existing platform
for deploying a solution that
lets you let people upload
videos from your website and
lets you moderate the videos
that you want to add to
playlists in your own account.
And we're going to be talking
about the next generation of
YouTube Direct.
And I don't want to give
away, again, too much.
But if you're a current YouTube
Direct user or if your
somebody who's thought about
using YouTube direct, but the
barriers of getting started
were a little too high, I
think they'll be happy
after this session.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
And I should point out, YouTube
Direct is an open
source project we have that
companies can use to solicit
feedback from their users.
They could post and say, we'd
like videos about such and
such a subject.
And all the users can run out
with their Android phones and
iPhones, take videos, and
then submit them.
And then the company can approve
them, in which case
they'll show up on their
own website.
And so that's a great way to get
videos from your users to
show up on your own web page.
So the next talk we want to
talk about is from Jarek,
"Mobile YouTube API Apps For
Content Creators, Curators,
And Consumers."
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
That's right.
JJ BEHRENS: Tell me more
about what I'm going
to be talking about.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
I'm sure you're very
curious already.
So we are planning to cover
API that is useful for
developing mobile
applications.
And, specifically, content
creation applications, which
is kind of the traditional
YouTube focus.
Content curation applications,
which is
new and very exciting.
And we have quite a few very
interesting companies that
have partnered with
us and implemented
these type of apps.
And then we'll talk about how
to implement best YouTube
consumption experience in
your mobile application.
We will have three API
developers joining us at I/O,
showing their applications and
describing their experience,
both with YouTube API
as well as mobile
development in general.
So this talk is really for
people that want to learn more
about what we have available
for mobile application
developers and then learn from
some very interesting
companies that have successfully
launched products
on these APIs in the
mobile space.
So it's a very mobile
focused session.
So if you're thinking about
mobile development, you're
doing mobile development right
now, this would be a great
session to attend.
If you don't care too much about
mobile development, then
I won't be upset if
you skip that one.
JJ BEHRENS: Can you tell me
a little bit more about
creators, curators,
and consumers?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
So as I mentioned before,
creation applications are
those that allow you
to capture, edit,
and upload the video.
So we've seen, historically,
desktop applications, web
applications that allow
you to do that.
But now, with the high growth
of mobile, there's more and
more functionality available
in mobile applications.
So one of the API developers
that we'll be featuring at the
talk has actually developed
a tablet and a smartphone
application that works very
nicely in concert to allow you
to capture content and then edit
it prior to uploading it
to YouTube.
So again, the functionality that
used to be confined to
high-powered desktops or web
apps at best, now is actually
being transitioned to mobile so
that you can do that from
your device on the go.
Curation applications are those
that really help with
content discovery.
So as we all know, there's a lot
of content being uploaded
to YouTube every minute
How many hours, JJ?
JJ BEHRENS: 60 hours
every minute.
And we have interns watching
those at all times.
That's how we do our
porn detection.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes, right.
So the question becomes how do
you actually find interesting
content out of those 60
hours per minute?
And we have algorithms, and
we look at a number of
methods to do that.
But we also have an open API
that allows developers to
innovate around it.
So this is really where the
curation applications come
into place.
Where either the apps help you
discover content through
whatever algorithms that the
app is developing, or they
leverage your social graph to
really help with friends'
recommendations.
So there's many approaches
at that.
And we'll be talking about some
of them at the session.
We'll also have some interesting
applications in
our developer sandbox at Google
I/O. So you can come
out and talk to the developers
of these applications to learn
more from them.
So the advantages that we see to
these apps is, A, they help
to really find content that
might be really finely
tailored to you and
your needs.
We think video on the web
is a big business.
So most of these applications
actually curate content that
is YouTube and not
only YouTube.
And that's totally cool.
I think the web is
a big place.
And then we also are interested
in really
increasing the time that people
spend with their mobile
devices watching video, as
opposed to sitting in front of
a TV. Or maybe both.
So that's really where these
developers help us.
And then consumers, really, the
reason why we mention that
in the talk is because we wanted
to describe some of the
approaches people have taken to
incorporate YouTube video
playback in your mobile
applications, for example, iOS
applications, Android
applications.
So there will be some
new, interesting
information at that talk.
And again, as Jeff mentioned,
I don't want to pre-announce
it right here, because I was
told that this is a career
limiting move.
JJ BEHRENS: Career
[? ending. ?]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But
I would like you to
join us for the talk.
JJ BEHRENS: And I know the A.J.
and Dror probably have to
get going before too long,
because they have to design
the features that we're going to
talk about at the next I/O.
But A.J., did you have anything
you wanted to talk
about, about what's coming up
at next Google I/O, at this
current Google I/O?
A.J. CRANE: I think Dror
pretty much covered it.
I think that I'm really
excited about the
presentation.
We're definitely going to be
going through a whole bunch of
great examples of people
who are using
the tool really well.
And showing some things that
work and some things that
don't for getting the word out
about your apps and showing
people how to use them.
So looking forward to it.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thanks, guys.
JJ BEHRENS: I noticed having
gone to just a couple of
YouTube talks myself, the PMs
are always the best at finding
the most amazing videos
that you can just
sit there and watch.
And then Jarek, somehow, is able
to connect to every hot
startup and get them to come
show their cool YouTube API
integration.
And I'm always left
scratching.
How the heck did they even
think of doing that?
That's fricking amazing.
So I'm definitely looking
forward to that.
DROR SCHIMSHOWITZ: Our job is
to watch videos all day.
JJ BEHRENS: I want your job.
So next at Google I/O, we have
a talk from Greg, who
unfortunately is not here,
called, "HTML5 At YouTube,
Stories From The Front Line."
Greg and Zoltan are
going to give that.
Jeff, do you want to talk
about that one?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, I mean
I'll just give the quick blurb
based on what they have in their
session description.
For those of you who saw our
I/O talk last year, it was
Greg, and me, and Jarek talking
about the new, at the
time, HTML5 video playback
via the iFrame embed.
So this is Greg coming back
again for another year with
Zoltan, who is one of his
fellow engineers.
And they're going to talk about
some new things having
to do with HTML5 video and some
other aspects of HTML5.
Not directly the video type
itself, but other things that
they've been using to build a
really cool desktop and web
browsing experience.
Sorry, desktop and mobile
web browsing experience.
So I'm personally looking
forward to this talk.
JJ BEHRENS: I'll
take that one.
And we got a question
from Brian.
Will the I/O sessions be
live-streamed again?
Maybe dubbed questions
streaming to mobile?
What about that, Jarek?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So there will
be a fair amount of the
sessions streamed.
I don't think all of them
will be streamed.
And I'm not sure exactly about
the sessions that we're
describing here.
We will, however, very quickly
upload the videos from these
sessions and make slides
available.
So if you miss a session or if
you're not planning to come to
I/O, we'll publish the
videos of these
sessions very quickly.
And then some of the sessions
will live streamed as well.
I think the limiting factor
there might be actually the
uplink bandwidth from the
Moscone Center that we'll have
at the event.
So not all the sessions
going on in parallel
will be live streamed.
But they will all be recorded,
including ours.
JJ BEHRENS: Are they going
to post the videos to
something like Vevo?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
We'll post it to
Google Developers Channel.
If you want to watch it on Vevo,
I think it might be a
little difficult to find
these videos there.
But I'm sure they'll be plenty
of bootleg videos from these
sessions that will be available
all over the web.
JJ BEHRENS: The next talk we
have is "YouTube API Plus
Cloud Rendering Equals
Happy Mobile Gamers."
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes, so I'm
a happy mobile gamer.
And what we are trying to cover
in this talk is really
how do you solve the problem of
capturing, and coding, and
uploading video game play
footage on a mobile device.
So gaming is really
big on YouTube.
And if you are a gamer, you know
that there's tons of very
interesting gaming content.
Anything from [INAUDIBLE] clips,
to tutorials, to bugs
that are captured
in the games.
And all that is very interesting
to watch.
So historically, again, we have
a lot of content coming
from desktops, consoles, and
not as much from mobile
devices yet.
So in this session, really, we
want to cover how do you
implement video capture
on the mobile device.
I'll give you a couple of
example architectures that
support this, show you
a couple of demos.
And then really focus on the
cloud-based approach that we
have been prototyping for quite
some time that allows
you to really offload some
of the heavy, intensive
processing from the mobile
device into your data center
if you have one.
So that's the focus
of that talk.
JJ BEHRENS: And if they don't
have a data center?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: If they don't
have a data center,
there's, fortunately, processing
capability
available for purchase.
So you don't have to
build your own.
You can use something
off the shelf.
JJ BEHRENS: And then we have
one called, "New YouTube
Android Player Tools Session
And Code Lab." Boy, that's
especially vague.
But I know that's an
exciting session.
Let's talk about that one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Maybe I could
take a stab at this one.
Again, we can't really go into
details, but there's two
things I wanted to talk about.
One is, if you're building a
mobile Android application and
you want to incorporate YouTube
video playback in your
app, you probably know that
there's a bunch of different
approaches ranging from
embedding your web view to
kicking off the YouTube app.
And they all have advantages
and disadvantages.
But none of them are exactly
what is needed to develop a
good user experience with the
large flexibility as far as
the control over it.
This is something that we
are planning to address.
And we'll go into details
in the session.
And so that'll be on day two
of I/O. And on day three,
we'll have a code
lab around it.
So if you come to this session,
you will learn more
about what we actually are in
the process of building.
And the following day, you will
have a chance to get your
hands dirty and start working
with some of the content that
we are covering.
I did want to mention that if
you are in Europe and you
would like to learn more about
this technology, we are
planning to have a Hackathon
around this in London.
That will be on July
6, 7, and 8.
So it's a weekend.
We'll soon be sharing more
information about it.
But again, since is the forum
where we pre-announce
interesting things, accidentally
or not, I thought
I'll take advantage of that.
So we'll post some more
information about this on our
developer forum and on G+.
But I would encourage
you to check it out.
If you are not coming to I/O,
but you still would like to do
some hacking with us--
my t-shirt, by the way,
says, hack [? you. ?]
And yes, so there'll be more
information coming.
JJ BEHRENS: Unfortunately, the
timing doesn't line up right
to give a talk on live-streaming
at the same
time as the Olympics.
But you can't do everything.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, although
that would be an
expensive talk, because I'm
sure the hotel prices
especially in London are going
to go through the roof.
JJ BEHRENS: Probably.
And then, Jeffrey, you want to
talk about, "Master The Latest
YouTube Data API Code Lab."
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
I'm not going to go into too
much details about what we're
going to be covering, the new
or the latest in the title.
JJ BEHRENS: You [INAUDIBLE]
API.
You're not even going to
tell us what it is?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
It's exciting.
We'll leave it at that.
So we have some new stuff that
we're going to be unveiling at
Google I/O.
And for those who are going to
be attending in person, I'm
going to be running a code lab
that'll give folks a chance to
see things before the general
programmer community, give
some feedback on some new things
that I have available,
and write some pretty cool
applications based on that
technology.
So definitely worth
checking out if
you're going to be there.
JJ BEHRENS: And I know that it's
pretty hard to get into
Google I/O this year,
considering it sold out in
like 10 nanoseconds.
If people want to follow along
and figure out what the
coolest, newest YouTube API
is from home, what do you
suggest they do?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
definitely watch the videos
that we're going to be posting
of the I/O sessions
soon after the fact.
For the code labs, we're
not going to be
posting videos of those.
But I think information about
what we're going to be talking
about is going to make it into
our public both Google Group,
and we have our blog, which
is apiblog.youtube.com.
We have, all of us,
on Google+.
I tend to link to all the
cool stuff that I find.
So follow us on Google+.
That's probably the recommended
ways of doing
things nowadays.
JJ BEHRENS: The downside to not
making it to Google I/O,
you don't get all
the cool toys.
But the upside is, you
don't have to pay.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'll probably
[? stay, J. ?]
Would you like to come?
JJ BEHRENS: I know.
And the Googlers, we
never get the toys.
We show up, and we work.
And we watch everyone else
get the cool toys.
Then we have two webinars, which
you can watch before
Google I/O.
The first one is called "You
Tube For Your Business".
Then we'll start a very
non-technical examples of how
you can use YouTube
for your business.
And then unlike Dror and A.J.'s
talk, I will go all the
way to the opposite spectrum
and talk about extremely
technical ways to tie into
YouTube for your business.
And I'll give simple
applications
all along the way.
And I'll also be showing
a little bit of code
all along the way.
It's the very broad
spectrum of ways
that you can integrate.
That's a fun talk.
I've given that a couple
times before.
And then the last talk--
excuse me--
we'll be talking about using
YouTube APIs and Ruby on Rails
for educational apps.
Everyone always asks me, what
does Ruby on Rails have to do
with educational apps?
And I always say, what
does peanut butter
have to do with jelly?
Absolutely nothing, but they
go together really well.
So that ought to
be a fun talk.
Fairly soon, we're going to be
opening up to questions.
And so if you want to start
typing questions into the
comment area of the Google
Hangout, I will start doling
out those questions.
But in the meantime, Jeffrey is
going to talk about one of
my favorite subjects, which is
using the YouTube API from
JavaScript.
And he's going to talk about
our new CORS support.
I think he might even
have a demo.
And we might even be able to see
this with screen sharing.
But go ahead, take
it away, Jeffrey.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
Thanks JJ.
So those of you who do subscribe
to our blog or our
Google Group might have seen an
announcement sometime last
week, where we officially
told the world that
we had turned on--
or we are going--
CORS support for the
YouTube API.
JJ BEHRENS: What's CORS
support, Jeffrey?
JEFFREY POSNICK: So CORS is a
way of enabling [INAUDIBLE]
service, like the YouTube API,
to receive requests from
JavaScript clients that are not
served on the same domain
as the API itself.
So CORS stands for Cross Origin
Resource Sharing.
And it works around the
normal limitations
on JavaScript code.
The security model, basically,
does not let the JavaScript
make a promote HTTP request
to an arbitrary server.
And that was all well and good
especially in the early days
of JavaScript.
But now we have a situation
where there's tons of
web-based APIs out there.
And having to deploy server-side
code, having to
spin up an app engine instance
or run your code from some
other arbitrary server
[INAUDIBLE]
overkill if you're primarily
developing a web-based API.
It requires extra
infrastructure.
It requires an additional skill
set if you happen to
just be a JavaScript
programmer.
So I'm personally really excited
that you can do pretty
much everything having to do
with the YouTube API now
purely from client-side
JavaScript.
So I wanted to show off one of
the demos of something that
you can do now that you were
not able to do before.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty sweet.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
And I think that this is really
just the tip of the
iceberg, what I'm going to
be showing here now.
The YouTube API is huge.
You can do a very wide variety
of different things.
So hopefully your imagination
will be inspired a bit by what
we're showing off.
So do you want to switch
the focus to my
screenshare right now?
JJ BEHRENS: We can see it.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
You can see it?
I just wanted to make sure
it gets recorded.
So this is just a sample page
that we have set up here.
And if you go to the blog
post [? announced-- ?]
here, let me pull up that
blog post here.
Go to the blog post, there's a
link to this page if you want
to try it yourself.
And what this sample shows
is a few things.
First, it'll show how you could
use OAuth 2, which is
our recommended authorization
slash authentication mechanism
for doing purely client-side
authorization.
So you don't have to have
any server-side code.
And you don't have to ask
the user for their
username and password.
It goes through purely
web-based flow.
And the credentials are entered
on Google's site.
So you know what?
Let me just share
that screen now.
Because I want to show people
what the login looks like.
I do not want to show people
my password though.
But hopefully, this
will work fine.
Let me actually login with
my personal account.
I clicked on the Authorize
Access button.
I get taken to this
web page that's
hosted on Google's structure.
It's all accessed via
HTTPS obviously.
You're not giving
your credentials
to any third party.
It's a really nice, clean way
of doing authorization.
A lot better than older
approaches like client login,
where you have to give your
username and password directly
to a third party application.
So I'm going to sign in.
I'm going to make this window
a little bit bigger.
Add that account, and then I get
taken automatically back
to the other page.
So let me share that
window now.
And you can see that
I am now logged in.
So the first thing it does is it
knows who I'm logged in as.
It says I'm logged in as Jeffrey
Posnick over here.
And that's done via a call to
the YouTube data API made from
JavaScript that, basically,
passes in my
authorization token.
And it gets back my user
profile, and it gets back my
display name.
We can take a quick look
at the code later.
But I want to run through what
the app actually does.
So basic metadata here.
And we're going to be uploading
a new video file.
It just asks for the title,
asks for the description.
We load the list of different
categories that are supported.
And that category list
is actually loaded
dynamically as well.
And I don't think these
video picker--
so I don't think the Open File
Up dialog box is being shared
with you guys.
But I basically clicked
on Choose File.
I clicked on Choose File.
I got an Open File dialog box.
I chose a local movie file.
At this point, I can
just click Upload.
And what's happening here
is using our standard
browser-based upload
flow-- and that has
existed for a while.
But one piece of that flow
requires doing an HTTP post to
our servers and passing
the metadata.
And that was never possible to
do before via JavaScript.
So you would be in a situation
where the upload flow was
mostly web-based, but you still
had to have this little
bit of server-side code in order
to actually perform this
browser-based upload.
So now, there's no server-side
code at all.
The full source code
is on this page.
I stuck it all as part of the
same big documents just
because it's basically
a sample code.
Obviously, you might want to
break this out into different
JavaScript files.
And I'm not going to claim that
this is the absolute best
practices for doing this
sort of thing.
But I think it gives you a good
example and code that you
could steal and use
in your own code.
So this takes care of things
like you [? turning off ?]
OAuth2, setting the appropriate
request headers
for making your YouTube
API requests.
It's using jQuery for doing
the actually Ajax calls.
Let me pull up one specific
Ajax call here.
So this is, for instance, how
it's getting the display name.
So it's making an Ajax call
saying, this is the URL I'd
like to get.
It's generating the headers
that include your
authentication token.
And it gets a response
back and parses
out the display name.
So it's all nice, based
on call backs.
It's just doing Ajax as if you
were doing it against a local
server except it's going
against our own
server in this case.
So that's pretty much
what's going on.
I encourage folks to steal this
code, get inspired, by
what I'm doing.
Hopefully, improve
it a bit too.
And go out and hack
some JavaScript.
JJ BEHRENS: That's fantastic.
I'm super excited about that
client side, all client side.
Let's go ahead and take some
questions and hopefully
provide some answers.
Jeffrey is already
providing them.
So Alexandre Passant at--
he has two questions.
This is for the Q&A session.
One, is there any music related
features in the new API?
For example, search by artist.
Jeffrey, what do you think?
JEFFREY POSNICK: No.
So this is certainly something
we hear about a lot, and
people wanting to find, for
instance, like the official
music videos for a given
account, which is somewhat
easier because they're all
uploaded in the same account.
But sometimes official music
videos might be spread across
different accounts, and you just
want to find everything
that's a Lady Gaga video
or something like that.
So you can kind of do that
now based on the publicly
available metadata.
But you get false positives
if you try to search for
everything from Lady Gaga.
There's nothing stopping an
arbitrary person from
uploading a video and tagging
it as Lady Gaga.
That situation is probably going
to be the same for what
we're talking about
with this new API.
There's not directly anything
new and certainly not anything
we can announce, right here
related to that unfortunately.
JJ BEHRENS: Good
guess, though.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: The next question
is, you mentioned helping
businesses to interact
with users.
Any plans to direct
screencasting features in YouTube?
Jarek?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Screencasting
features like
the ones we were using
here in G+?
JJ BEHRENS: I don't know.
Do you want to talk about
Wirecast for YouTube
[INAUDIBLE]?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Well, Alex,
you're on the call.
Do you want to clarify
what you wanted?
ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes, I was
thinking actually two things
like easy screencast. Because
right now, if you want to do a
screencast for a product, you
just use ScreenFlow or
something like that, and
then you upload.
So that may be good, but
something direct
to do that on YouTube.
And the other thing is--
and since we're using user
testing to have resource
[? code ?] the software, that
will be good as well if you
get something--
I don't know--
YouTube or Android to
do that [INAUDIBLE]
as well this way for
the product.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, we don't
have it out of the box.
We have partners that
implemented this.
And it's also very platform
specific.
So no plans right
now, I think.
And JJ alluded to that.
We have several app developers
that implement this
functionality.
In fact, one of the companies
that builds that will be at
our developer's sandbox
at Google I/O
showing their solution.
So they use YouTube API
to upload in the end.
But typically, what happens is
people want a lot more than
just a basic recording.
So what their soliciting us to
do is edit, modify, change
things, before you actually
perform the upload.
But we don't have anything that
would make it simple for
a simple use case.
It's an interesting
idea though.
We will definitely pass that
on to product management.
JJ BEHRENS: In general, if
people have good ideas, what
should they do with
them, Jeffrey?
JEFFREY POSNICK: They could post
it in the Google Group.
They could approach us
on Google+ also.
And there's all sorts
of different ways
of engaging us nowadays.
A possible approach is putting
it in our Issue Tracker as a
feature request. And there's a
link to Issue Tracker from our
developer website.
But I tend to like seeing things
in the Google Group.
I pay a little bit more
attention to that than the
Issue Tracker.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, Jeffrey is
currently responding to the
Google Group.
We have like a two minute
latency some
days, not every day.
Some days, it's like three
days when he's out.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I take
weekends off.
JJ BEHRENS: So do we have
any more questions?
We've got two guys live
and any others?
Otherwise, I'm just going
to make them up.
No, no questions.
What's the best question you've
seen on the Google
Group this week, Jeffrey?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yikes.
Best question.
Let me take a quick look.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, see, part of
the problem with responding
very quickly to questions, as
Jeffrey does, is you really
have to be [INAUDIBLE].
If you try to store any
[INAUDIBLE] about the
questions before answering
them, it slows you down.
And so it's kind of like
an internet router.
You want to be routing the
packets not saving information
about the packets.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Indeed.
So actually, something that came
up a couple times in the
Google Group in the past week--
and hopefully will be
fixed tonight as part of our
Wednesday night YouTube push--
is the new restrictions that
we had in place on minimum
sizes for YouTube embedded
players.
Jarek had a nice blog post a few
weeks ago where he spelled
out what those restrictions
are.
Basically, you need to make
sure that you have your
embedded player at 200
pixels wide by 200
pixels high at the minimum.
Obviously, you can make it
bigger than that, change the
aspect ratio.
But that's the bare minimum.
And we've had some developers
who have been posting, saying,
I have an embedded player that's
either exactly 200 by
200 or a little bit bigger,
and yet I'm still getting
playback errors, saying that
my player is too small.
So starting tonight, we're going
to actually change the
logic a little bit that we use
for calculating whether the
player is too small and,
basically, fix it so that the
size of the control bar doesn't
count against you when
making that calculation.
So you can't really be expected
to know how big the
YouTube control bar
is going to be.
And I think that's the way we're
going to address this is
by hiding the control bar a
little bit more aggressively
in those scenarios to make sure
that there is 200 pixels,
in each way that's available
for playback.
JJ BEHRENS: I see.
And I really don't
understand this.
I mean, I want my playbacks
as large as possible.
Why would anyone want a YouTube
player smaller than
200 by 200?
You can't even fit Lady Gaga
into such a small image.
JEFFREY POSNICK: She will
not be contained.
I don't know.
There are legitimate reasons
for wanting a
really small player.
I'm actually working right now
on something that displays a
whole bunch of thumbnails for
videos that are uploaded in
your account.
And I want those thumbnails to
turn into playable embeds when
you click on them, basically,
which is all doable via the
YouTube player API.
But I don't want to have to--
I'm actually doing inline
playback in this case.
I'm not making a letterbox or
anything where it takes over
the whole screen and shows
the really big embeds.
So I want the embed to be still
small enough that it's
not crowding out everything
on the rest of the page.
JJ BEHRENS: I know a question
that comes up that I have to
answer a lot is should people be
using the old object embeds
with the new iFrame API
especially when they want to
mix in some JavaScripts?
Jarek, what do you think?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, this
is a very good question.
So we have released the iFrame
embed a long time ago.
I think it's been over a year.
And then we have then followed
up with an iFrame API.
In fact, we spoke in detail
about iFrame API at Google I/O
last year with Greg and Jeff.
One thing that we're looking
into right now is what it
would take for us to remove
the beta status
of the iFrame API.
So there's a lot of concern at
that point to make sure that
we can comfortably say,
hey, this is ready
for production apps.
Since as of today, it's still
in the experimental stage.
So we're working very hard to
make sure that there's really
no need for you to use the
object embed in the old
JavaScript API anymore.
And then get the iFrame API
ready for production.
So I would rather not discuss
specific timelines, other than
say that it's very soon.
And I'm personally very
excited about it.
Because, really, what it means
is that applications that need
cross-platform functionality
will be able to comfortably
use the iFrame API and then work
reliably no matter what
the platform is, whether it's a
desktop, a web browser, or a
mobile web browser on
a platform that
doesn't support Flash.
JJ BEHRENS: So tell me, when
would the object embed not
work if you're using the
JavaScript API for it?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: If you don't
have Flash, then typically
object embed won't work or, at
best, it will work, but there
won't be API support.
So say, on the iOS, you can
embed a video into a web app
or a web view.
It will render properly.
The playback will work.
But you can't actually get
to it and control it.
Because there's no API exposed
through a Safari plug-in that
is implemented as a part
of the Mobile Safari.
So while playback works, there's
no way to get at the
video and use it with an API.
So that's really
the case here.
Plus, we really want to
transition as much as we can
toward the iFrame embed so that
as new platforms appear,
we can figure out how to offer
best playback experience for
them, rather than forcing a
developer to go through the
motions and do some weird things
with the embed format
depending on what
the platform is.
So that's the advantage of
using the iFrame embed.
And then if you have a platform
that you work with
and you find that the iFrame
embed is not working as
expected, let us know.
Because that's something that we
intend to fix and optimize.
There's a fair amount of
platform specific work that
goes into the iFrame embed
implementation.
But then the advantage is
again, it fits everyone.
So we don't actually have to
force the developers to think
about all these different mobile
platforms and others.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I wanted to
add something to what Jarek
was saying.
We still do plan on having the
ActionScript 3 version of the
Flash player accessible
via the object tag.
It's still fully supported, so
this is not us deprecating it.
And we know that one important
use case for that is if you
happen to be a Flash developer
and you're writing a Flash
application, you're writing a
Flash app, something that
requires the host to be in
Flash, and yet you want to
playback a YouTube video from
within that application, you
still do need to use
our older player.
It's not the exact same syntax
as the object tag.
But it is directly requesting
the Flash
version of the player.
And you are going to continue
to be able to do that.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
That's really helpful, because
I like to code
HTML5 five days a week.
And then I do Flash Tuesdays
and Thursdays.
Do we have any other
questions, or
shall we wrap it up?
Well, thank you guys
for joining it.
It makes it a lot
more interesting
when people are watching.
Thank you, Jarek.
Thank you, [? Pong, ?]
who you can't see.
Maybe you can wave?
[? Pong ?] is our software
engineer pretending to be a
technical, audio visual
engineer.
Thanks a lot, Jeffrey.
Thanks a lot to our
two visitors.
And Dror and A.J. who went back
to work, figuring out
what we're going to
do next quarter.
So thanks a lot guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
See you, guys.
ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Thanks.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Thanks.